today's one minute Monday is practice if  you want to have success in any field in  your life in your business and you need  to practice to be one of the best in the  world at what you do if you're not  getting the results you're looking for  yet if you're not seeing the results  coming in chances are you're not good  enough yet in what you're doing your  product isn't good enough your service  isn't good enough your customer  experience isn't good enough and you  need to get better if you look at the  people who are at the top in their field  athletes musicians entrepreneurs artists  what got them there was a ton of  practice and beating on their craft you  have to do this you have to get better  you have to practice every day to get  better to become one of the best in the  world if you want to achieve the success  that you're after believe you guys liked  this video thumbs up leave a comment  subscribe we'll see you soon